on a pas mal je veux pas passer en soit
venu
quant aux sommes qu'il faut de
l'intelligence est pas suffisante
trois par jour minimum entre les seins
avant de vous coucher chez l'autre n'est
pas du préventif en fait le docteur que
je sais moi c'est du du curatif
désendettés à dire c'est quoi c'est quoi
ça sert c'est une aspirine doliprane
dans ce cas là mettez lui la danse
arrête
il a fait des dons pour réunir les
techniques et mon parquet après magic
les très contents ils super faire de
temps et paris qui s'en sort très bien
aller attar émission rémy émis sa à
paris mais mon père de amy je suis déçu
parce que tu fais là des fois je sais
pas si j'ai reçu par andy greene
qu'est ce que tu as fait irruption vers
n'importe quoi
c'est que le début regardons ensemble
est parti je tombe à repartir comme
avant
on a frappé encore plus fort peu partout
peux pas t'empêcher de toute la bande
oui d'abord il vos accessoires et plus
qui se fait alors des belles mères
poussent à petter concluante pistolet à
eau pétards écoute à tous
tant besoin de porte quoi